you're watching good day las vegas with
john langler heather mills
sheri swensk and nate tannenbaum
good day las vegas live local now it's 5
13 it's friday morning and we are
heading into 4th of july weekend so to
celebrate we are highlighting some of
the best barbecue spots in the valley
all morning long and this one is a good
one with a funny name though ron futrell
joining us live from roadkill grill in
the northwest valley
it is good the name though ron
oh no that's the name makes it here the
roadkill grill john mull's roadkill
grill is where we're at to start things
out this morning we are smoking this
morning for independence day weekend
hold on we already got some
burnt ends
in here okay
find that that's what's happening all
over the valley if you look at what's
going on right now people are getting
ready for independence day weekend that
means get the barbecue out get smoking
chuck frohmer is here chuck how are you
doing this morning you're up bright and
early or is this this is not early for
you
this is every day man every day you're
here good morning las vegas good morning
smoking let's go smoking in here what do
you say yeah we got brisket we got beef
ribs and we've got some burnt ends going
right now
so you can see we actually use pecan
wood so it gives a really heavy smoke
you're smoking we'll wait for it to
clear out a little bit before you post
on that can you can you see in there
armando
my eyes are burning right now chuck you
know that oh you'll be crying in a
minute that's for sure you are crying
right now yes i am
okay so let's grab something out of here
what do you have that looks good
everything
all right there's a beef rib
this has been cooking now for about 16
hours
generally we wrap them before we
actually pull them off but we don't have
time to do that tomorrow for the tv
let's see
they've also got it here i got to
mention this too there's sauce out here
i come out here just to get the sauce
sometimes the mild and the spicy stuff
both are great then i take them home and
i pretend like i made the sauce myself
nobody else does that do they chuck them
oh yeah everybody
yeah just heat it up say yeah i've been
working all night on it i'm working all
night making this sauce no i got it at
john mull's roadkill grill okay beef
ribs are cooking right now they're
smoking and we're cutting them up um so
these are a good way to cut let me see
is that a left-handed knife yeah that's
the left hand hang on are you holding
this this came from iowa keep talking
hold up i know you got a greasy mind
what are we doing here all right so we
got a beef rib you're going to slide
right down there one more plate where am
i slight you're going to turn this up
this way stand it up like this
and just slide your knife right down
that
just go on the other way just go right
down the bone this way yeah
take the meat off there you go okay
all right
now look at that look at how juicy that
is no that's dude that should seem good
yeah if i hold mother what if i hold the
mic now is it okay
it's already greasy it's my fault man
i'm sorry hey nate says hi and he wanted
some food to take back by the way nate's
been out here before oh nate he comes
every christmas man okay
we see nate all the time you guys have
food for them we can take back to them
okay
nate they love you out here
they come do the job
on the job nate come on let's do it
again
and nate still looks the same that's the
best oh he looks the same he's getting
younger i think all the time okay so we
got some of this stuff we're going to be
bringing it back nate here's some of
your haul from the roadkill grill john
moles out here it's right in the middle
of the community so it's a little bit i
don't want to say hard to find but you
got a gps you'll find it oh yeah if you
want it you'll find a challenge that's
the whole idea and make it hard make it
good you know what i mean yes yeah
follow the smoke
okay we're heading off to another one
here in a bit so let's get hitting the
road and we'll grab some food and uh
chuck thank you i appreciate it man
thanks ron thanks chuck appreciate that
roadkill grill uh well known spot and
yeah wash your hands ron please before
you hop scotch
finger looking good i hope chuck looks
vaguely familiar
he's been on diners drive-ins and dives
two or three times guy fieri
also loves the roadkill grill because
yeah my meat consumption is very limited
but that's worth it yeah and if you're
ready
for the fourth that's an option you
don't have to do all the barbecuing
yourself a couple of quick
recommendations salami okay hot links
i go burnt ends
see now hot links reminds me of home
texas yeah
all barbecue joints have hot links and
and i mean got some in the freezer right
now do you really